former minnesota police officer was
found guilty in the shooting death of
dante wright the jury which at one point
seemed on the verge of deadlock found
kim potter guilty on two counts of
manslaughter david schuman from our
minneapolis station wcco was in the
courtroom when the verdict was handed
down
we the jury on the charge of
manslaughter in the first degree
find the defendant guilty
kim potter showed little emotion as the
jury found her guilty of first and
second degree manslaughter moments later
her husband called out to her as she was
placed in handcuffs
[Applause]
potter shot and killed dante wright as
he tried to flee from a traffic stop in
april claiming she mistakenly fired her
gun thinking it was her taser
prosecutors said potter's actions were
reckless and negligent and she should be
held accountable
while testifying on the stand the former
police officer broke down and apologized
i'm sorry it happened
i didn't want to hurt anybody
what to say
the fatal shooting sparked protests in
the city of brooklyn center near
minneapolis where at the time former
police officer derek chovin was on trial
for killing george floyd
on thursday a different reaction outside
the courthouse
wright's mother katie bryant thanked the
community for their support police
officers are not going to continue
to pull their gun instead of their taser
and we made this happen for cbs
morning's i'm david schuman in
minneapolis
potter faces up to 15 years in prison
for the most serious charge but she
could end up serving only half of that
because of state sentencing guidelines
prosecutors say they will seek a longer
term